thank you
okay
okay thank you and thank you
and thank you
and thank this whole area
for show
first show
it's the first
oh one
what a dream come true thank you
everybody uh welcome to the pete holm
show i'm pete holmes
yeah that that checks out
it sounds like by your plaza we do have
some fans and some friends here which is
lovely but i have to imagine the rest of
the people watching are wondering who am
i
and why do i have a talk show
and i get it look at me i i kind of look
like a lesbian val kilmer
i just mean i
i have this
friendly kind of open face i don't
really have like that slick talk show
vibe you know what i mean in fact i'd
like to imagine that there are millions
and millions of different universes each
slightly different from the last and
this universe the one we're all in
currently is the only one where i'm not
a youth pastor
doesn't that just feel right i i
shouldn't be here
i should be in a carpeted gymnasium with
a guitar with a rainbow strap just like
who wants to rap about the lord you know
what i mean
but here i am somehow impossibly hosting
my first show and i really want this
show to be amazing so i thought one of
the best things to do would be to tell
you a story of one of the most amazing
shows i've ever been to
um so i don't go to a lot of music
music concerts
evidenced by the fact that i called them
music concerts
but uh my joy quota for the month was a
little bit low and i saw a show that
looked like it might be fun so i bought
ticket don't judge
i bought i bought tickets i feel like
you might
i bought tickets to see uh
enrique okay
bought tickets to see enrique iglesias
uh yeah yeah it was a good i should say
i bought ticket to see
enrique iglesias no one wanted to go
with me
and i feel like some of you are thinking
that uh maybe i went ironically
no
the show started and i was like this is
exactly what i was hoping for
it was amazing i loved it i did this
four times i went like this i went
i'm 34 years old
older than jesus i did this four times
like a small child seeing santa claus
like the real santa claus i did that it
was amazing i was in the cheap seats i
was one of the few men there it was one
of the only white people there
it was just me and like latina latina
girls
latina latina ninas
latinas
just me and an ocean of latinus
and i'm way taller than them i'm just
like a lighthouse
moving to their rhythms
and the show was amazing
but because i go to so few concerts i
actually forgot about the concept of
encores
so i was the only person that thought
the show was over
the lights came up they left the stage
and it was just me just like
he didn't play hero
why wouldn't he play hero
that's like his biggest song
started very quickly now it wouldn't be
a story if enrique just came back out
onto the main stage and sang hero that's
not a story i wouldn't waste your time
this is a story
three feet in front of me there was a
second stage a circular stage that i
didn't know about a secret stage that
lowered listen to me it lowered
steam shot out of it and enrique [ __ ]
iglesias
rose up from the ground just like i
could be your hero
like han solo being released from
carbonite
steam everywhere he's wearing that army
hat that he wears like he's fighting and
winning a sexy sexy war
i was like
and before he sang he was like i need a
volunteer
is this voice offensive and
i need a volunteer
stay thirsty my friends
he's like i need a volunteer uh
i feel some of you excited that it might
be me it's not me
i would have ruined a lot of young girls
lives if i was like oh do it
enrique he goes i need a girl
and he points to this one girl and goes
you
are you 18.
and she goes see
and no [ __ ] c was she 18.
she was 15. i swear to god the light was
dancing off of her braces
but he was like close enough
he brought her up he brought a child
onto the tiny stage and started grinding
on her i feel a lot of you backing away
i feel that but if you had been there in
the magic of the moment you would have
been like me we were all like by the
mouse
we were singing other hits of his that's
how excited we were
and he started grinding 15 grinding her
learner's permit fell out of her back
pocket
but she loved it it was like her prom
her quinceanera
and losing her virginity all rolled into
one moment
was it legal
who's to say
but it was the best night of our lives
and i hope this night is great too let's
make this a great night
are you ready for a great night